[Music]
on this Friday night two hostages freed
from Gaza Hamas releases two Americans
held captive for days the push to
release all the
hostages Jeff simple is in the West Bank
asking Palestinians if Hamas really
represents them Hamas they are
Palestinians they're nuanced responses
truckloads of life-saving supplies
waiting to be allowed into Gaza why they
are still stuck plus an international
soccer Legend hangs up her cleav every
chance that a guy gets I want a girl to
get Canadian Christine Sinclair's
incredible influence and her gold for
Equity global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us there is finally a glimmer of
good news from Israel and Gaza two of
the 200 hostages held by Hamas in Gaza
have been released they are two
Americans a mother and daughter Judith
and Natalie ranan from Illinois they
traveled to Israel for a family birthday
party on a kabut in southern Israel and
were taken by Hamas when its Fighters
stormed out of Gaza on October 7th
killing over 1300 Israelis they have
been held captive somewhere in Gaza
since then tonight the Israeli
government released this photo of them
being escorted by Israeli soldiers back
on Israeli soil the two women are
relatives of the wife of a former
colleague of mine at NBC News Martin
Fletcher who tells me the family is both
shocked and Incredibly happy they are
free President Biden said in a statement
he is Overjoyed but there remains deep
concern for the remaining hostages
including it's believed two Canadians
Israel says 20 of the hostages are
children including an infant Hamas said
today all the civilian hostages could be
released if the Israeli air strikes on
Gaza stop this is how the US Secretary
of State react reacted to that I would
uh not take anything that U Hamas says
at face value our position is clear
every hostage needs to be released and
needs to be released now today Israel's
defense minister said the Final Phase of
his operation will be what he called the
removal of Israel's responsibility for
life in the Gaza Strip and the
establishment of a new security reality
for the citizens of Israel in Gaza that
long promised humanitarian Aid still has
not arrived the Rafa gate from Egypt
into Gaza failed to open again today
despite assurances from the American
president that Israel and Egypt both had
agreed to it it's believed a sticking
point is Israel's concern nothing that
could Aid Hamas gets in the Israeli air
strikes on Gaza continue and every day
of that Siege supplies of food water
medicine and fuel keep dwindling the UN
Secretary General went to the Egyptian
side of the Rafa gate today he called
the Convoy of Aid trucks waiting there
the difference between life and
death it's absolutely essential to
respect International humanitarian law
it's absolutely essential to protect
civilians and it's absolutely essential
to make humanitarian Aid come to the
Palestinians in need Crystal ganing
begins our coverage tonight with the
pressure to get that Aid into
[Music]
Gaza crates with more aid for those
trapped in Gaza arrived in Egypt along
with the UN Secretary General getting
any of it to those who desperately need
the life saving items is the issue on
Friday the American president pledged
again that deliveries will happen I got
a commitment from the Israelis and
president of Egypt that the cross should
be open the highway had to be repaved
because it was very B very bad shape and
I believe that with the next 24 to 48
hours the first 20 trucks will come
across with day 20 trucks is nothing Aid
group say before Israel declared war and
blocked all shipments of food water and
fuel into Gaza 450 trucks made
deliveries
daily more than 1 million people were
told to leave their homes in the north
by Israel Defense Forces the lucky ones
are Sheltering in tents others sleep in
hospitals or church compounds or are
crammed into homes with multiple
families all are looking for food and
water the amount of people in the house
and the use of water it's not enough for
two days
maximum Palestinians are suffering the
Gaza Health Ministry which is controlled
by Hamas said Thursday night 18
Palestinian Christians were killed in an
air strike they were Sheltering in the
compound of an ancient Greek Orthodox
Church which sustained damages Israel
says it was targeting a nearby Hamas
compound
save the children is calling for an
immediate ceasefire saying since October
7th one child dies every 15 minutes in
Gaza as a result of air strikes people
dying stop bombing stop Israelis
aggressive for Gaza stre deepening the
humanitarian crisis another call for
people to move the Palestinian red
crescent says its operations at alad's
hospital in Gaza City are facing an
imminent threat after the Israeli
military ordered the hospital's
evacuation the hospital is reportedly
housing more than 400 patients and
roughly 12,000 displaced
civilians the question now is how much
more the humanitarian crisis will
deteriorate as all of those people are
forced to wait 48 hours or possibly
longer for some clean water and
something to eat Donna crystal ganing in
Jerusalem
thanks
in the West Bank thousands turned out
for funerals for 13 Palestinians killed
during overnight raids by Israeli forces
the Israeli media says Israeli troops
used a drone before engaging in a
prolonged gun battle with armed groups
in a refugee camp Israeli Border Police
say one of its reservists was also
killed tensions have flared in the West
Bank since The Siege on Gaza began over
80 Palestinians have been arrested
including Hassan yusf he is a Hamas
spokesperson in the West Bank
although most of the attention has been
on Gaza concerns are growing over the
occupied West Bank it is not run by
Hamas but by the Palestinian Authority
which has renounced violence and
condemned the attack on civilians in
both Israel and Gaza the surge in
violence though is fueling concern the
Palestinian territory could become the
next front in a wider War our Jeff
simple and photojournalist Tim Lee were
in the West Bank today Palestinians in
the occupied West Bank are no stranger
to clashes with Israeli forces but
nothing like
this the result of an hours long battle
Thursday between Israel and Palestinians
the Israeli military even launching an
air
strike the Palestinian government says
the latest violence brings to 75 the
number of Palestinians killed here since
the Hamas
attack I feel uh very Furious this
Palestinian Canadian grew up playing
hockey in Toronto before moving to the
West Bank a decade ago she says
Canadians don't understand what life is
like here for Palestinians it's very
hard because there are checkpoints
everywhere you can't get to anywhere
without having uh Israeli forces
stopping you and that's something the
world also doesn't see is that we are
all in a
prison as soon as Friday prayers ended
the demonstrations began pales Ians in
the West Bank angry and helpless as
their friends and family in Gaza are
bombed relentlessly their blood bth is
taking place in Gaza Israel says the
bombing will remove Hamas and bring
peace Palestinians both old and young
say that's impossible they think they
are doing this to to to make safe for
thems to make security no there is no
security for people they killing
children you have to avenge the lives of
the people that died what if someone
like bombed Canada what would you do
Hamas does not represent the Palestinian
people prime minister Justin Trudeau
says the Palestinian people don't
support Hamas but many here flew the
militant group's green
flag Enchanted Hamas protects us Hamas
they are Palestinians they are a group
of resistant Fighters fighting for our
people and our land and when October 7th
happened everyone went crazy and oh my
God how does that happen to them but
they don't know that this has been
happening to us every day every
day so a smaller crowd has now marched
here to the edge of the Israeli
settlement of bill which has been a
common flas point of
late and just in the past few moments
here we saw one of those Palestinian
protesters shot in the leg responding to
Palestinians throwing rocks Israeli
troops shot three protesters the outcome
so common and predictable that
ambulances were on standby just meters
away Hospital staff told Global News all
three patients are expected to recover
Israel typically uses rubber coated
steel bullets and they are just started
shooting at us because they don't want
our voices to be heard this protester
covering his face because he could face
arrest resistance should happen it's a
normal reaction towards all the violence
that we have been living for all these
years and if the violence in Gaza
intensifies the West Bank seems likely
to follow Jeff simple Global News
rala the US state department has issued
a worldwide travel alert Americans it
says should exercise Extreme Caution
while overseas because of what it calls
increased tensions and potential
terrorist attacks the Pentagon confirms
drones and Rockets have targeted US
forces in both Syria and Iraq this week
us officials also say a Navy warship in
the Red Sea shot down missiles launched
by huti forces in Yemen missiles it
believes were headed in the direction of
Israel the Canadian government says it
is preparing to evacuate hundreds of
Canadians from the region with the help
of the military if needed there's no way
to do that in Gaza right now where
hundreds of Canadians are stuck the news
came in a briefing from Global Affairs
Canada which our Mercedes Stevenson was
listening to Mercedes Donna the
government giving an update today saying
there are now 430 people who they are
trying to help help get out of Gaza
you'll notice that's a higher number
than we were talking about earlier this
week when it was around 300 that's in
part because the Canadian government
says they have managed to negotiate for
people who were not initially included
and considered foreign citizens to be
allowed to leave with Canadians so now
we're talking about Canadian citizens as
well as Canadian citizens family members
so perhaps spouses or children and
Canadian permanent residents all being
able to leave through the Rafa gate if
and when it opens it seemed that
Canadian officials were cautiously
optimistic they said that the lineup of
Aid getting in would be the biggest
signal if it's able to move in maybe
some foreign citizens will be able to
move out but for now they are cautioning
Canadian citizens to wait where they are
but be ready to move at a moment's
notice here's what they had to say we're
not going to tell Canadians to move to
that border until we know for sure it's
going to be open and that it is open for
the purpose of foreign Nationals being
able to move out of that gate the
Canadian government is strongly advising
any citizens in Lebanon to leave now
while they still can there are
14,500 registered Canadians in Lebanon
Donna an awfully big number and the
military is moving into position to be
able to evacuate them if necessary okay
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes Quebec's controversial idea
coming up what's behind a plan tuition
hike and why many students are not happy
this Saskatchewan government has passed
what it's calling its parents Bill of
Rights it's a new law requiring parental
consent for children under the age of 16
who want to use different names or
pronouns at school to get the bill
passed Saskatchewan's Premier Scott Mo
used the notwithstanding Clause a tool
used to override some sections of the
Canadian Charter of Rights and Freedoms
Saskatchewan's opposition NDP and the
province's Human Rights Commission are
among a number of groups opposing the
policy there's lots of controversy
surrounding Quebec's plan to double
tuition for out of Province students
attending English universities the
Quebec governments insists the move is
necessary to protect the French language
but English universities warn it sends a
signal to anglophone students outside
the province that they are not welcome
and as Tria isra reports one
postsecondary institution is already
warning it may not survive the tuition
hike Quebec has some of the best
universities in Canada but if you're a
non- quebecer who studies in English
your degree is about to cost twice as
much we're scrambling now and Clay
bendowski is from Dawson Creek British
Columbia his daughter was planning on
going to Bishops in sherbrook Quebec
until the bill skyrocketed that's an
extra
$40,000 that's that's a lot of money
we've put a fair bit of money away for
her education but that's that's just a
huge bump to it Quebec plans to jack up
tuition fees to
$177,000 for outof province students up
from under $ 9,000 the move will hit
Quebec's three English-speaking
universities McGill Concordia and
Bishops I've talked about a catastrophic
impact I stand by that uh the potential
impact of these measures uh could
threaten the the existence of the
University I am committed to stop the
decline of French in Quebec the Lego
government says an influx in anglophone
students is causing that decline adding
Quebec is financing the education of
people who return home after graduation
the Lego government has been generally
pretty successful at playing with that
identity heartstring but there are
warnings this time it will backfire
Quebec gets uh as many students from
outside of Quebec as uh they sand
outside of uh of the province the
business Community says the proposed
hike will cost the local economy
hundreds of millions of dollars while
Montreal's mayor Valerie plant fears her
City will become a harder cell this
measure what it will support is more
people going to Toronto universities
let's be honest the federal Innovation
minister is also warning the tuition
hike will make it harder to recruit
talent to Quebec a province with one of
the worst labor shortages in the country
Tera is Global News news got no Quebec
the US state department and the British
government say they're concerned about
the departure of Canadian diplomats from
India and expect India to uphold its
obligations under International
conventions of diplomacy prime minister
Justin Trudeau says the Indian
government's move to revoke diplomatic
immunity from 41 Canadian diplomats and
their families violates international
law this is something that has
far-reaching consequences for the
Diplomatic world that I know many many
countries are very worried about the
Indian government is making it
unbelievably
difficult for life as usual to continue
for millions of
people last month the Prime Minister
said there are credible allegations
India's government was involved in the
killing of a sick leader in British
Colombia that angered India's government
which denies any
connection still ahead fears from
Lebanese Canadians of Lebanon being
drawn further into the conflict with
Israel
[Music]
as Israel masses its troops on the
border with Gaza it's also making
military plans to protect its northern
border with Lebanon where rocket attacks
by Hezbollah have already been happening
as Dan Spectre tells us that violence
has Lebanese Canadians worried about
their loved
ones the persistent exchange of fire
between Israeli Defense Forces and
iran-backed Hezbollah has caused
civilians along both sides of the border
between Israel and Lebanon to flee their
homes including the southern Lebanese
town of Daria I come came from from
because had some attack
from the threat of Lebanon being pulled
deeper into the conflict is bringing up
bad memories for Lebanese Canadians half
a world away the punishment is always
for everyone Sam Fel lives north of
Montreal now but was in his early 20s in
Lebanon in 2006 when Hezbollah and
Israel engaged in a month-long War he
remembers Bridges and even the Beirut
Airport being bombed he's worried for
his elderly parents still living there
whenever the war erupts uh basically uh
areas will be isolated and uh whenever
areas are isolated this means you're
you're you're not going to have enough
food you're not going to have enough
power Hezbollah has warned it is ready
to get more involved in the war
meanwhile Lebanon is still recovering
from the 2020 Beirut Port explosion is
suffering from an ongoing financial
crisis if a window breaks then people
don't have the money to fix a window so
imagine if we get a destruction similar
to maybe you might have seen some of the
pictures of the destruction that's
happening in Gaza Toronto resident Ramy
s De decided to leave Lebanon in 2009
after he was shot in his car he was
caught in the crossfire between rival
political groups and still has shrapnel
in his liver he says War would cause a
humanitarian catastrophe for his country
for about Lebanon for the next Century I
think I'm against any extremis group I'm
against anyone who decides to go and
kill especially in the name of God Fel
is trying to get his parents to Canada
as soon as possible many Lebanese
Canadians are just hoping their country
stays on the sidelines Dan Spectre
Global News
Montreal end of an era next to soccer
Legend calls it quits the difference
she's made to the women's
game
Canadian soccer player Christine
Sinclair is 40 years old now and she
knew she couldn't play Forever today she
announced she'll retire from
International competition at the end of
this year I had the pleasure of
interviewing her a few years back she is
as self-effacing as she is brilliant at
the game always talking about the team
effort not just her own but the fact is
no one has had a bigger influence on
women's soccer than she has here's Eric
s
a defining moment can be traced to the
under 19 World Championships 21 years
ago when Christine Sinclair and her
generation established Canadian women's
soccer on the world stage Sinclair
became a goal-scoring Wonder in college
in the pros and in international play
Canada by the 2012 Olympics Canadians
had caught soccer fever Sinclair leading
Canada to a bronze medal the winning
goal scored by Diana mat we're a unique
country and that it is women soccer that
put soccer on the map first for us and
and truly I mean sink is at the heart of
that Sinclair's goal scoring Feats would
culminate with a goal that surpassed
Abby wach for the most International
goals ever the closer she got to goal
the lower the blood pressure went the
lower the heart rate and she was just so
calm in front of the net so calm that
Christine Sinclair's goal scoring is
unparalleled in the history of the game
190 goals internationally more than any
Other Woman and 63 more than the topsc
scoring men's player Cristiano Ronaldo
six World Cup appearances scoring in
five ties a record for men and women and
of course capped off with two bronze
medals and Olympic gold two years ago
Sinclair was simply the face of Canadian
soccer for 20 years but as she told
Donna her bigger aim was to see equality
for girls and women in the game equal
the men every chance that a guy gets I
want a girl to get we're moving in the
right direction but like at a very slow
pace her Legacy may be just as profound
off the field fighting for pay Equity
taking her fight to Parliament Hill at
the community center that bears her name
Sinclair is an inspiration to young
girls like I grew up watching her I went
to Vancouver and watch her now I was
young she's just been my idol for my
whole life pretty much she like built a
huge pathway for me all of my teammates
and all these young girls that are
coming up Christine Sinclair posted
today I am preparing to tie a bow on an
unbelievable International career in the
90th minute of our journey she put up a
simple image uncaptioned hanging up the
most prolific cleats in the history of
international soccer Eric senson Global
News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Friday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your candidate is the Christine Sinclair
Community Center in her hometown of
bernabe BC the facility was renamed in
her honor in 2021 she said back then her
love for the game of soccer was forged
on the fields right there and the next
generation is working hard to follow
inner footsteps thanks for watching far
and Nasser will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and I will see you again on
Monday have a lovely weekend
[Music]
bye-bye